so brand you want to narrate what
happened for anybody who's listening to
our you know the audio
portion of the podcast what are we
rolling are we in
hey there you go hey welcome back
everyone welcome to another corridor
cast i am trying to lift a chair with my
foot i'm calling the jake into a song
don't believe my eyes all right there we
go
y'all probably saw the thumbnail or read
the title and saw that ian hubert was
here so
here he is
[Laughter]
yeah if people want to watch on youtube
yeah but just tell us if you want us to
cut anything out or if you say anything
and you're like i take that back just
say it out loud
we're trying to catch that then we will
actively ignore it and upload it no no
no
we've cut out so much from these
podcasts no one would
no one's the wiser
that's not true at all
i know i just say it to get people's you
know i i've only pulled that card one
time two years ago
wasn't it looks like we started like a
rant that's like something that already
touched upon a bunch and then like and
then the podcast started somehow after
that it was like really good like
we have this like little five-minute
chunk of the beginning like has nothing
to do with what we talked about so let's
just take it out no i was talking about
something else oh okay yeah why does it
exist anymore so it's okay i already
made this joke earlier today but i said
that peter has fled
the studio in anticipation of ian's
arrival
[Laughter]
obviously there's a grudge there's
there's a there's competitive you know
creator clash boxing match and peter
we'll get we'll get each other someday
two ik rigs in blender and have them
fight
yeah i love i'm so excited it's short
yeah let me see you short a while back
excuse me so excited it's finally coming
out yeah yeah it's just have we
announced anything about that yet no no
cool it's coming at some point
it's a secret
no not anymore
it's fine
that just adds intrigue
yeah
and it's a really good demonstration of
just like what modern tools can do and
then like the ending just pushes
everything to the point where i forgot
that there's tools and techniques being
used it's just all these it's the thing
we're talking about on uh uh react where
there's these quick transitional
cutaways where it's like wait a second
that conveyed a lot of information to me
but you had to construct every single
bit in this and i just like accepted it
as like that yeah so yeah it's really
i'm excited to see it again
so a lot of things just got mentioned
here first off you are on an episode of
vfx arts react with us today yes uh
that's gonna be coming out at some point
we just filmed it today
um also peter's short film that he spent
a year working on called
a year longer than that
much longer than that at least two years
if not longer
years ago well this was all part of his
like senior thesis at college really
yeah
he went to
yeah went to school did he skip out at
the end he dropped out a month before
graduating
peter i hope you don't mind sharing your
life story with everybody on the
internet i think i think it's a good
time
i can't speak on that i don't know i
think it's important to have artists
share their stories of
their education so that's the second
hand though
[Laughter]
of someone else's life story
because
yeah but when you say that peter fled he
literally got onto an airplane over the
weekend to go to india
oh and i wish i could i'm just sorry i
don't want to talk about him too much
but how how he fled
is a whole story too
yeah but i think
that's where it gets private i think
it's i think we're going to be flat he
left after a wedding and drove from l.a
to san francisco at freaking midnight
okay that's why i'm saying now now
i advised against it but
i'm not i don't want to talk about it
the point is we were checking in on him
hourly
and he's alive
[Laughter]
yeah
well ian you were also at this wedding
over the weekend for
the beautiful
clinton jones
and kim
yeah she was there too
[Laughter]
yeah so that was such a that was such a
good wedding it was friend
so happy
i know it's like hey all my friends are
here this is really nice
i know it's like oh man like why don't
we guys why don't we just get together
and do this like all the time
yeah you know like because but i that's
that was my feeling too it's like all
the hard work or you you do or whatever
you
whatever you're striving towards like
moments like those
are kind of like the payoff so yeah uh i
think it's pretty cool and special so
guys i'll rent the little ranch the nice
you know christmas tree lighting you
bring the photo bus or photo booth and
like
it's like a dance florida dance some 90s
hits yeah yeah sometimes you go to a
friend's party and they have like don't
worry don't worry i already got a bunch
of beer
you know this is it's like the cool
version of that where there's an
expectation to dress up nicely
you know but it's yeah yeah it's great
it's elevated yeah
i've been wanting to set up my projector
in my backyard uh just up on the side of
my house oh yeah and and have like a
smash tournament
one one day i'll get that going
nice ian uh
you're you hail from like the the
northern forests right
the northern forest northern forest
territory
yeah
um
so
you have been working on this
series called dynamo
since we were children since we were
children yeah actually when did you i've
see it's weird because i feel like i saw
art that you made way back in the day on
like 3dtotal.com
because i believe is like when did you
start working with blender was it when
he was a child he just said this nico so
i started working with blender in 2004.
i started working on dynamo in like 2007
started writing random ideas in
sketchbooks i just i vaguely remember
somebody
doing these sci-fi landscapes in blender
and they would mainly do it through
booleans way back in the day well that
was bryce 3d probably right maybe nah
this is like it wasn't that could be
somebody but then like i associated
associate that with you because i think
around the same time as when i saw your
first dynamo stuff
you started working on oh interesting i
don't know yeah i've been doing it doing
it for a minute
and i don't know it's kind of it's kind
of fun to have
a project that's evolved
kind of with me just kind of something
where it's like it's always
representative of wherever i'm at yeah
um
i've never everything that i've released
so far has always been trying to be part
of like the setting the stage that i've
never actually gotten to like the plot
of the which i do after like
in fact this is the 10-year anniversary
like 10 years ago to the day i was in
amsterdam like shooting a thing for the
blender institute i was about to say i
remember that film and it got attention
and was getting like you know the the
people calling me like hey what would
you want to come to la and make a
whatever and i was like no no i'm going
to go back to seattle and work on my my
personal stuff you know going to see how
far i can push that and after a decade i
can say i've released 40 minutes
i'm averaging about 40 minutes per
decade and that is uh
i'm like yeah but someday i'll figure
out the formula
to like speed things up so i can do more
than that which is where every time i
see like sam just demoed his uh virtual
production setup or your guys's virtual
production setup and i'm just like so
jealous that i'm like i'll just
literally send you the parts list of
like the bare bones set up for what you
need
and then when you get it just call me
and i'll just walk you through something
i would love that so i even have this
because it's because like it looks crazy
and yes it's crazy because i have like
all these extra features on there right
now but if you're just on a green screen
and you want to track the camera and you
don't want to deal with the bs of normal
green screen tracking
super easy it's super easy to deal with
my whole like workflow and even
aesthetic right now is kind of around
like i'm shooting everything wide
um
i have a friend who films some stuff for
like terence malek and he's like we're
filming everything on 12 millimeter
because it like it shows the person
relative to like the environment and
just makes it feel that much more
immersive and i'm like yeah and you'd
get all the tracking markers
that's what i'm doing now
um
and you just do the traditional you know
computational tracking yeah yeah yeah
yeah and sometimes i just like tell it
to find you know points of contrast and
i'll brute force it and delete all the
bad ones but i've even like gotten to
just like you just need eight points
do you guys remember the first time you
put video footage that you shot into a
timeline and you started cutting it
together and then you got to that point
where you realized that it looked and
sounded nothing like what you had
imagined when you shot it you thought it
was going to be top gun you thought it
was going to be a movie of epic
proportions or probably something like
that at least that's how i was
filmmaking is a
painstakingly detailed process where you
need all sorts of different things to
combine in a single video picture image
to give people the emotion and the style
and the taste that you are going for in
your story and one of the best ways that
we help that process around here at
quarter digital is by using today's
sponsor storybox storyblocks is like
your best friend when it comes to video
creating it's got everything you need
high quality 4k b-roll images audio
motion graphics after effects templates
and more and you can get them all
royalty-free unlimited with their
unlimited all-access plan you download
it you put it in your footage and into
your film it's really that easy i wish i
could explain how much more difficult
this process was years ago when
resources like storybox were not
available you can work creatively almost
in real time you know when your software
program freezes and you got to restart
it or reboot it or it glitches out and
it and it stops that process of thought
where you are literally creating at the
speed of thought in process well
storybox helps you do that that's what
happens in every video it's never just
pointing a camera at something
and filming even this right here isn't
just that
so anyways huge thanks to storyblocks
for always coming through and sponsoring
this podcast and and sponsoring what we
do here at corridor digital uh if you're
interested head on over to
storyblocks.com
corridor cast or click the link in the
description below that's storyblocks.com
and uh get your best friend for video
creating it's really great thanks for
listening and now let's get back to the
podcast
that's like fun you know because you
know you started doing this so long ago
i feel like he has the really same like
kind of goal that we really shared which
is like
i want to make it look like these crazy
things i'm seeing i'm just kind of doing
it by myself but i feel like computers
should make it easy somehow so i'm going
to explore the tools and like you know
little by little everything evolves at
the same time like so now where you
where you are and like the visuals
you're making the stuff you're putting
out compared to like how you're doing it
back then to you what's been like the
biggest shift that you've seen in all
that time wow um honestly the past few
years have been
absolutely bananas it was always getting
better you could always kind of render
more but like with the the modern
generation of gpus
just like there was always this
separation where you'd set things up and
then you hit render and you'd wait to
see the materials and lighting and the
compositing and all of that looked and
now the fact that like they can just be
feeding it to you live means that it
doesn't feel as if there's like all
right i'm telling a thing to do a thing
and it's doing a thing it feels so much
more like you're reaching your hand and
you're like i can just
it's just doing whatever i want it to do
and that's made it feel so much more
like play yeah and uh i think that's the
thing that like like real artists as in
like people who work with paint and clay
oh yeah i feel like that's where they're
like yeah how to work the computer this
stuff is real time like once computers
have reached that now you're like oh
this is what they're talking about
it's like that same sensation yeah play
and it's a different part it triggers a
different kind of part of of the brain
it's a whole different way of thinking
about stuff and like being able to
set up complicated node things where you
can set up like rules for like okay
above a certain point i want to switch
to like this type of material doing this
except with this is like
i don't know
that's a really interesting way of
thinking about it because that was like
that's like the biggest problem when you
like are starting out with high-end
software and you don't really know what
you're doing and you hit render and it
takes a long time to go you know it's
like it's like it's like less artistry
but more like
guesswork in a way you know it's like
you could paint a picture or why don't
we program this huge like paintball gun
array to like shoot it out like what's
going to take longer to do it's like
just painting it or
programming this thing to go burnt and
like oh crap
half the ball is shot in the wrong
direction you know i mean when i started
learning 3d rendering and stuff like
that i was using mental ray in 3ds max
and
i couldn't get it it was like all these
different settings for global
illumination all these things it's like
there's
sliders more numbers is more accurate
but
more time to render and i you know it
was a lot for me to figure out and it
was it was a huge challenge but when i
started learning
rendering on octane render it changed
everything because it's like you just
turn it on and it just works and now
because the rendering was just working i
didn't have to worry about it too much
suddenly i was able to really start
learning
more about how textures work how
channels on textures work and how
lighting interacts with stuff like that
because i wasn't having to worry about
how to render a shot i know and like
those early renderers like mental ray
and stuff like they come
like defaulting to like the worst
settings
like they're not the fastest settings
they're not the best looking settings
they're just like
arbitrary settings where it's like
instantly it's like you want to do
anything good you instantly have to
learn
all all these dumb settings and tweak
them back to something that's either you
know you skew it towards performance or
quality you know and but it's it neither
at its beginning you know
that was real that was really
frustrating i'm glad those days are gone
but yeah like rendering has been huge um
i love all of the the photo scanning and
machine learning able to like just uh
abstract stuff and like extract stuff
and turn it into something else and like
just play with reality all of those
tools are wild i think the yeah machine
learning stuff like
the weird capturing volumes of spaces
and things are gonna
blow everyone's mind um did you guys get
in the mid journey yet oh yeah dude i
have a full subscription and everything
oh is it cool
i've made hundreds of images mid journey
is this uh ai image generator that's
very good you can make
very specific images
if you've seen that i've seen those
crazy like brain exploding like ai it's
like a step below do you have
demonstrations red dolly too
it's the same thing
i don't think well
everything i've seen from it looks like
better than like dream that like wombo
yeah yeah i don't know is it dolly too
if it's deli too it might just be an
implementation it's an implementation
but not i can't speak specifically they
don't want to share too much information
about it just yet but it's a discord bot
that basically is just running you feed
it anything for instance uh
existential crisis looney tunes
that's so good um
i did a few uh dbz ones here uh goku as
a non-profit ceo
wow
that's actually really good here's the
other dbz one obama as a dbz character
[Laughter]
iron man as a baby but i miss i i i was
a typo and i wrote
iran man as a baby
there he is iran man
probably my favorite is uh
one of these there's like surprise
pikachu grim reaper wow
that's pretty cool yeah and you can you
can put any sort of like art style have
you seen people saying octane render at
the end of their pictures to make them
look like cool photo real renders so i
haven't seen that yeah that's a thing
that people do now i was talking about
this with ian too the other day and it's
like wait a second this
can do a lot of the busy work of like
you can you can so like i know you put a
ton of work into like okay convenience
store stickers posters wall you know all
that deep micro detail but this can like
it seems like it can help fill in the
gaps
of some of that asset generation of like
oh shoot how do i find like like
something of this style of a convenience
store banner you can like get mock-ups
of that quick if it's not
you know something that's too important
to your story or something but still oh
at least keeps it in the right same
style you know i like to think like
what's after like imagine okay i can do
this in 2d
what if it gets combined with some 3d
infrastructure so then you can get like
it's going to get crazy dolly for 3d
models an environment like just you can
drop straight into unreal engine like
yeah just by typing it into a problem
what does that mean yeah it's just
what's after that we're going to hit a
point where people are literally just
generating their entertainment on the
fly i know that's what i'm saying like
it's going to be the joke is you're like
what do you want to watch tonight babe
it's like i don't know really wish there
was a new iron man movie out but i wish
it was like a cool mashup with like the
titanic you know and you're like all
right iron man titanic romance action
film and then it goes and it's just
there's playing content and then the
next hour and a half of your life is
watching that movie and it's got like a
decent intro middle and end and your
apple watch like senses your pulse and
like
here we go you can tell if you like it
if you like it's like we'll just keep
going that direction they're not like
yeah the temperature it's got the
temperature slider there that's
constantly going up and down so this is
i think uh we've talked about this a
little bit in the past i know this is i
don't want to turn this into an ai
episode did you answer arnold's arnold
schwarzenegger as a mortal kombat
character yeah
oh i tried that one too because that was
a great prompt
his chest is his face yes
for everyone
even everyone watching right now i
apologize because you can't see the the
images we have
maybe there's a way to like
it's what it sounds like drop them in
yeah so is it exactly what it sounds
like that's what it does so everyone
okay so okay if an ai made avatar would
people say
the same like or what if i reveal to you
that an ai had made avatar you know or
something like that it's like
oh it's like oh i get it it's like a
recycled storyline but with some new
graphics or something like that but at
the same time
you know that that thought process is
applied so frequently in so many other
places you take whatever human beings do
in general like that's the concept you
you're inspired from stuff like in in
music there's only
so many there's a finite amount of notes
on a piano so if you're writing in that
scale or not on like using these those
in
intervals of notes like there's only so
many progressions and chords and stuff
that people generally use you know
there's the majority of songs are
you know
one of you know i don't know a couple
dozen patterns effectively right they
calculated they can only be at max like
1700 songs yeah something they were
going to run out probably but like it
goes back to that we this weird thing
where you know i'm like oh yeah all the
ai text generation it's just recycled bs
being spat back to you i'm like
that's already a lot of things actually
yeah so
what is the difference
between that and a human doing it human
just like knew hopefully and it was like
when's the last time any of us made
anything that wasn't just kind of like
what does
a rehash what does even mean like a
darker batman
you know is that new now like i've made
it even darker and you know like watch
this and you turn your ai like the
darkest batman
and then it comes down it's like ooh
that's new
that's that's that's original i get to
see a batman go that dark i've never
seen that yeah that's very dark
but like that's all that's effectively
like all it is you know i'm saying
they're gonna burn out and just be like
they're all gonna give up on media by
the time we're 30. not like yeah you're
born five years from now i know because
like you look at the matrix and you're
like why is that original it's like you
know
trapped in a simulation as a concept has
been around is it well directed yeah
obviously
cool story sure but like ultimately
from a conceptual standpoint it's it's
it's the it's an excellent execution of
a concept that
already exists right you know what i'm
saying so like you could you can't like
to play devil's advocate you can say
it's recycled you can say it's not
100 new what's new about it is like the
novel execution of it well it's like the
concept of like you can all read the
same sheet music but you perform it
differently
you know every performance is unique
yeah so i suppose that's that's what it
comes down to
yeah i don't know anyways
weird
i'm against it darker i'm just i want to
see the darkest batman i can't believe
you would share such a hot take i know i
know i just i am
it tells us tell me about it yeah it's
one of those things that feels as if
like
we can do you know the whole like but
should we like all right we can type in
anything and create like a picture like
that's cool
but what does that
i feel like the purpose of art is you
know the the idea of you're trying to
reach across
a divide like it's you know trying to
find humanity even if like you're like
alone you can like read a book or
something feel as if like you're oh
picking up something that like somebody
else has put down yep and if you get rid
of that it is just
distraction it is just they're probably
between content and art i guess yeah
it's just it is the difference between
content and into content and i feel like
if every show you watch is the best show
you've ever seen because it's calibrated
exactly to you and your viewing habits
and it's reading your pulse and all of
that but you're only ever watching it
like alone
that's like that almost gets rid of yeah
what art was like supposed to if art is
supposed to be a form of expression and
a
a different like
tool for communication
an ai takeover of that is basically
like a disservice to humanity and what i
hate is that it's gonna work they it
could generate you know the best movie
you've ever seen or like whatever and so
i would it'd be like why would i ever
watch a thing that wasn't perfectly
calibrated to whatever my chemical state
and what i want to watch exactly right
now and it's like because
like we're already so separated by like
this 10 000 years of human evolution's
change within like since we were
teenagers like this giant additional
variable of like you never have to talk
to anyone again and you're going to be
like happy what does that do i just i
don't think we're quite like we
definitely raise some kids in like you
know an island with it and just see what
they do first
before we release it on mankind
yeah everybody's definitely a pioneer on
this frontier but i also know it's like
that's a very you know
fearful old man take but it is but it's
true it is true
yeah i've seen a lot of technologies
growing up that maybe weren't the best
for
mankind but it poked the right like
chemical buttons and so we're like yeah
we're all we're all doing this cancel
culture
and like look at my phone for
i get pooped and i'm just like all right
phone time just like scrolling i'm the
doom scroll i wish i didn't do that if
it does work out if this future works
out it'll be oh let's at least have like
a cool chat where we send each other
like
prompts that we thought were really
funny for these ai films you know like
the arnold schwarzenegger mortal kombat
you know like yo here's my hashtag and
he's like oh nice and now you i pull
that
you see his prompts for the feed to load
up some of his prompts on your feed
right now
and the academy award for the best
prompts goes to
nikko
shared shared
uh yeah
mortal kombat character
unreal engine 5
shared by 3 billion people
[Laughter]
bravo
how did you do it
i feel like right now i'm just typing in
random stuff this one was kind of funny
i feel like it's human nature to do to
like crave and desire human touch right
like not physical human touch but like
the human elements sometimes it's
physical
well sure but like i'm just saying with
all this ai stuff generating these
things it's like it the novelty factor
is still high because this is new it's
crazy wait a person didn't actually
create this thing it looks amazing
that's gonna wear off in the not so
distant future and everyone's gonna be
like yeah yeah machines make everything
what's the big deal i think there's
gonna be a
it'd be like a dream
like
you wake up and you're like i just had
the craziest dream and it's like yeah
but it's very hard to like oh yeah we
have to be like what it's like i have my
own like that i watch like i don't want
to hear about your ai movie but at the
same time it's like
i don't know maybe this is just me
trying to grasp on to this hope but i i
feel like going forward there's still
going to be like a certain
element of wanting to
have that sort of personal touch on
things like we were just talking we're
talking about this ai stuff and yet
we're really talking about the prompt
masters
you know it's like it's the product that
we were getting interested in we're
interested in the actual art not the
content ian if you reconsider this
future now but with prompt masters as a
factor does it change your outlook no
because they would be at the top
and it's just like the next stage of
like you know this code masters
neuromancers they would all cyber poetry
drunk on their power definitely you
troll everyone they like that's the
other thing too is like you combine that
with like
all of the analytics being able to
control you for ads stuff and they're
just like it's too much they understand
us
too much they just make us their slaves
with these great like
amazon movies
yeah
well it's like i
dude i feel like amazon and netflix
movies and shows are basically already
this kind of they're like pro it's
prompt masters all right
that's like the vibe i get that's why
you don't know what they're still very
analog people are still making the
movies people are still making them but
like it feels like somewhere there's
behind the scenes there's a prompt
master who's making the scripts with
gpt3 or something like that
i've been watching so many just
bizarrely good shows lately that i've
been wondering like did they do it did
they like
figure out how to just make good shows
ludicrously good shows because every
show i'm watching is just like this is
the best television i think they
probably did honestly this is i think
they correct i mean i'm serious like it
sounds ridiculously but i think
generally speaking they're kind of like
yeah this is how you make a good tv show
you do these things like it's hard to do
and you need skilled craftsman you need
a lot of money but it's
a b c d with the list i was like damn
look at that tv show yeah it's like for
dozens of decades people were searching
how to do a backflip
you know and someone figured it out no
i mean you can learn how to do one
yeah and it's just you follow those
simple steps it's hard
but you can execute it perfectly
right now
i mean don't pull a muscle in your
stomach like i did
you've got like youtube muscle tell me
what if we couldn't leave this room
until one of us learned how to do a
front flip front flip back foot back and
which one's harder
front flips and back flips at the same
time flip front lifts and back
no it was it was on the description of
the corridor digital
youtube page
that's right you could literally go on
the wayback machine on the internet
and and pull up 2010 corridor digital
and that's what it says
those are the golden days when you have
a custom background and everything is so
cool yeah wait can you not anymore no oh
you mean it was actually like the back
you styled the whole page it was like a
myspace page back then yeah this is html
html coding for everything
so much cooler personally personally i
think that's way cooler yeah i had this
like halftone pattern you couldn't read
anything it was chaos yeah i love that
just like every graphic design element
goes
there's no theme across our site because
everyone can do it themselves i do feel
that the barrier to entry for creating
high level stuff obviously has been
dropping over the last decade or more
but i feel like the rate at which it is
dropping
is increasing as well especially with
all the ai stuff so it's like
it's part of the reason why i'm here
today like
at corridor and whatnot is because
from the beginning after i graduated
college with a completely different like
degree in in path in life but i i was
wanting to do visual effects in
filmmaking but i didn't want to be just
like some random name at the end of the
credits of a movie nothing against those
people i just like i wanted to have the
creative control to do what i wanted to
do and you i was at the time you know 10
15 years ago you're reading about how
like
robots are gonna take all our jobs it's
like every job eventually will get
replaced by like some sort of robot so
it's like okay what can i do
to ward that off as long as possible
creative decision making
so everything in my life has always been
trying to like put myself into a
position to make creative decisions
rather than
being just a generic artist who does
things that eventually you i mean you
are the tool in a lot of those
situations you know and though any tool
can be replaced with a more efficient
tool down the line but
i
i'm hoping that it it's going to be a
long time before
the actual creative decisions
are taken over or like the good ones the
main big ones that's what i'm hoping but
like this whole idea of the of the
prompt master here it's like
there's still a prompt master pulling
the strings on these puppets
i think these prompts whatever happens
what you really want to have happen at
the end of the day
is you want to just empower
a person to do what they're trying to do
excuse me which is what tools generally
do yeah yeah like a buzz saw gives you
the power of 10 men using non-electric
saws you know so it's like people with
saws going like anyone can [ __ ] cut
wood
so like
ideally whatever these tools are
like the saw gang
no artistry anymore dude just wait until
the axe getting used about what saws can
do so only used to be about a nice long
stroke you know naturally that spinning
circle who was it i was talking about
this recently
tangent here we go
no it was just like i think it must have
been at the wedding because someone was
talking about how it's like back when uh
like machines were starting to become a
thing like turn of the century nineteen
hundreds saggings uh saggings were
around
it's like john henry in the railroad
yeah yeah maybe i don't know something
along the lines of people are like oh
we're we're losing our soul to all
automation and whatnot but it was like
that
was the case and also not the case at
the same time yeah well it can like what
i was saying was the tool needs to
empower the person so like
whatever it is whether it's ai or
anything else like ideally what it's
really doing is it's empowering an
artist to make even more art or make
better art it's not necessarily
replacing the artist yeah and making
more content
someone is still making creative
decisions based on that sort of like
iterative loop yeah i mean like all we
are here you know and everyone in this
prompt masters really like look
like yeah but no seriously everyone in
this room all we are or just people who
are like
man i wish i could go to outer space or
i wish i could drive a cool robot with
lasers like you know we're just man like
that
except all the only difference is that
we've just dedicated a lot of time
and
lots of energy and time and resources
and money into figuring out how to
pretend how to do that or make people
think that we're you know does it show
the picture i was thinking about this it
was pretty cool i like that you might
want to see it so i spent some time oh
we're trying to get you we're just
finding a way to realize that in in the
world so that we can see it tangibly and
share that with other people yeah um and
so i think that is a good argument as
far as like if someone can type mortal
kombat arts arnold schwarzenegger in
there it's like
if that's their dream to see that like
that's probably a good thing i think
it's like the barrier to entry is
dropping but the
bar for high quality is raising
you know as like it gets easier to make
stuff we're getting more
what's the word for it's like
selective about our tastes i guess like
you know yeah what is considered good
anymore
we also hit that
difficult point where it's like
i mean i can't imagine would be like
trying to break out now like as like say
just a graphic artist or like even like
a cg artist like there's so many good cg
artists out there
i feel like the only leg up
one can have these days it's just having
done it for so long
because like you know what's the one
thing that somebody who's dedicated
their life to it who's 20 years old
doesn't have on somebody who's dedicated
their life to it and they're 30 years
old it's like well 10 years of
experience you know it's like that's
kind of the only
thing you can dedicate it's tough i mean
it's a little like there's a clear path
when it comes to like like moving
visuals because then it goes from pure
aesthetics to like storytelling yeah it
makes that there's a lot of stories to
tell us i mean you can still do that
with stills like there's you know plenty
of awesome books that are illustrated
out there too that you know yeah they're
just images but
when combined they make a story
you know like i mean that's where the
true true magic is and so i mean yeah
maybe netflix has cracked the code but
i mean that's it's yeah yeah their stock
price reflects that
yeah well other people are doing it too
other than that
i know i was just
our boy or old boy jimmy c i think it's
interesting um
i i think all the time about like 10
years ago where it's like i remember
everyone i knew had a web series and
like a webcomic yeah everyone was in
like multiple bands
um i was like a web series by the i have
not heard that phrase yeah so you guys
probably had a web series oh yeah
everything on netflix is a web series
that's true
you're right bigger budgets now but like
everybody had that like all right i'm
gonna use this new frontier to like kind
of express myself or like uh like when i
was a teenager everyone was in like five
bands and i'm talking to like other
people from my same old high school like
nobody's in a band and i think it is
what you're saying like
everybody can hear what polished good
music sounds like you used to just have
to be like a good musician in your group
of like 20 friends and now it's like you
know you're always comparing yourself
you're going to be in the instagram feed
against like
the best in the world and so i think
that actually has been kind of
that would be a little demoralizing
demoralizing people a little bit and i
think it's kind of a
like here's the high score list except
instead of it being your your town or
your state it's the entire globe yeah
yeah but it also works the other way too
because it could also be very inspiring
i was telling you this earlier that like
the work that you put out is so goddang
inspiring
because it's incredible
high quality art you know and the fact
that you're able to do it all on your
own is incredible and that inspires me
because i'm like wait
it's possible let it be demoralizing
let
go that's good good that was my goal
demoralized actually i stay up till 5
a.m and i'm like this will destroy ren
the demoralizing you feel is just part
of human nature's like a drive to be
competitive like it's like a fundamental
human aspect to see someone that's doing
something better than you are and want
to beat them at it and
and demoralization is like a it's like
that that's that's like a rite of
passage in order to get better because
it's the only way you can see yourself
for where you really are in your chain
of like your
growth yeah and so i i think it's super
important and the music thing is like
rings really hard with me because i've
been writing crappy guitar music
for a really long time and i just like
release stuff and i'm like yeah this is
kind of crappier than everything else
out there still
no still not still not there but like
i'm getting closer and i know i'm
getting closer because i'm hearing the
gap close like i hear stuff from
three years ago five years ago ten it's
like oh no like yeah it's it's actually
getting closer and i'm like starting to
understand that finally and it's not
something i invest all my time in
because it's you know side stuff but
like it takes that time and effort and
energy and like
motivation
of like getting demoralized and
overcoming that to to improve yourself
meanwhile if you're to show 15 year old
sam
the albums that you've put out yeah yeah
by
mix some stuff that sounds decent and
like wow cool like currently my first my
first song was recorded in final cut pro
yeah
you know i was so desperate to just
record audio somewhere
that i just use final cut pro i didn't
even have garage garage band didn't even
exist yet
dude
you still have all your mp3s back in the
day yeah i know they're all sitting
around somewhere sitting around
somewhere yeah
the same jams or older than that or even
older yeah yeah
yeah i mean that's that's the thing that
that is super crucial it's like it kind
of sucks because it's in your face
that's just art do you like dude
the life of an artist
yeah i actually think it's interesting
because like most filmmakers i know kind
of glorify a bit that that pure
creativity of being a teenager running
around in the backyard like with a
camera making whatever it's like where
why can't we find like that energy it's
like because we stop and we actually
make it good now
like yeah everything we made was bad and
we wanted to outgrow that but um at the
same time there is something like really
good about that energy which um it's the
reason i've loved you guys is stuff
because it's like all right can we keep
that energy while also like elevating
our craft and i think you guys have
really
thanks you've done that really good yeah
i feel like you've done the same
honestly dude it's the ape [ __ ] energy
the uh the episode that you were in the
what the yeah yeah were you the
pterodactyl dad the entire the actual
goal of that one like was or at least it
wasn't when i first shot it but looking
back at it five years later i'm like
this has
some of that ape [ __ ] energy yeah like
and i want to actually bring my modern
like the stuff i know how to do now to
layer like
a little bit of uh production value and
cg and stuff on top of it so it has that
like
drunk 26 year old like energy with some
polish to just kind of like i don't know
legitimize that stuff can
suck you can have the ninja monkey humor
if you want to and just like i don't
know i know i appreciate no no seriously
like that's a it's a the ape [ __ ] energy
like
you said that to me like
i don't know like four or four or five
years ago in like a text or something
but that like the concept has definitely
stuck it's just it's the idea of like
all right yeah i'm better at using a
camera now yes i can do more vfx stuff
or like i understand like even all right
get it starting with a better sense of
like storytelling and beats and stuff
like that
but
all you're doing is just using that as
like kind of a like a crash pad
effectively with a crazy idea and like
it's it's it's kind of like not
it's like knowing which rules are okay
to break so to speak too it's like
that's the combination there well this
horseshoe you got a horseshoe theory
here so when you're in high school
you're shooting a short video it doesn't
matter
right but you don't know that at the
time no you don't i mean you're you want
to make it good but it doesn't like
you're not going to get fired if you
make a bad video right you're in high
school
so it doesn't matter what happens
somebody's gonna give a [ __ ] if your
video is good or bad
you know
at least like you i'm gonna keep
focusing on that i'm gonna be good at it
and like four or five years later it
really matters now if your videos are
good or bad because you're like i'm
getting into this i need to prove to the
world i'm like taking classes whatever
eventually you're getting a job in it
now you're getting paid like it really
matters and then you do it for long
enough again where it's like okay i've
gone to enough film shoots now where
like i know i can probably handle it
even if i don't prepare
and then you start to enter the i guess
it doesn't matter again phase that you
were in in high school but now you have
all this experience so like that's
called
jaded
no but not not mattering versus not
caring is different okay just like going
on to like dude i'm not gonna lie the
son of a dungeon shoot for me it's it's
the ape [ __ ] stuff where like frankly
like i'm familiar with all the shots but
it's nine episodes i'm not going to over
plan this stuff so we go on set it's
like we watch a shot and we're like hey
should we go ape [ __ ] on this and just
have fun
you know what i'm saying like and that's
what i'm so excited about yeah because
it's like you've reached the point where
it's as state of the art and now like
the advancements are making it easier to
use and so it's actually kind of like i
mean you had to put in a bunch of like
front loaded work yeah the front edit
but now you can like the actual process
of shooting means you can
get to a head space where you don't have
to worry too much about that and you can
just like let things get killed yeah no
normally a green screen shoot is really
oh yeah you always focus yeah it's
engineering yeah you're grabbing
elements you're not like in it yeah yeah
a lot of scenes now we're sort of a
dungeon is like all four of us get into
the space they point the camera around
so we can see where everything is and
then we just start like goofing around
like not goofing around necessarily like
oh would this be funny like oh bob can
jump and then the elevator shakes and
we'll wobble and like like we talk about
we don't mention to d but then d does it
anyways because he's like in it also and
like you spilled the space and you play
in it but like sam made all the good
graphics sure
like and now it's all good to go it's
like the last shot we did on friday is
still the best example and like it's
it's just showing crosstalk bridge it's
like a tiny peak until like what we can
do is like i i i forgot what it was but
it was like oh hey we're on a bridge oh
but maybe we should be up and run with
like
we're like hey ryan can you stand on
these apple boxes like sure like oh
sweet it's like so suddenly ren can now
go like hey here's something that would
be fun i could do this i'm like that is
fun let's do that and like yeah we're
just sitting there that was planned
it's not that wasn't even on our shot
list it's just like that's right that
was a total bonus shot it's like it's
not it's not even playing it's like hey
guys you want to just do like wrap the
day with a fun shot that doesn't
that no one is playing for it's like
okay it's like all right we'll just do
the coolest shot that we did all week
basically and so now now we're like okay
how do we keep having fun with it yeah
it's all about being able to say
this is going to be fun you want to do
something fun everyone's like yeah sure
that'll be fun like it's not like
another shot you know i feel like with
with uh with virtual production you've
kind of reentered the stage of
like
black box theater slash interpretive
like dance or miming where it's like
all right there's me four of us and like
we're gonna make a scene like it's like
why instead of virtual production we're
gonna get two seconds like no it's like
we're gonna shoot for a minute or two
minutes
and but like we can't talk it's all body
language and it's like wide shots
there's four of us and we have like
literally a box to plan it's a big box
it's still a box
so what's a fun interactive thing we can
do with each other to tell a little one
minute long story and like that's kind
of what
these days are becoming now it's like
here's the moment in the story
let's make a little skit
you know in that space
i love that so much yeah i know that's
what the mandalorians kind of becoming
we're gonna get we need a green ladder
uh and i it would be cool to i think
maybe we can have some of these big
boxes those big wood crates we still
have make those green too
we need like green legos we need
literally a giant jumbo green lego set
to build out like mini mixed reality
sets and then you can have people climb
it and jump off it and roll around you
know it's like quadruple scale apple
boxes exactly we have them let's get
those like foam like
kid fort like things so it's like you
have the big blocks dude i'm just
kidding oh this is kind of small aren't
they i've seen some bigger ones okay
you don't want pads you know the pads
deform and then they create shadows and
whatnot even if they're green yeah but
you want to be able to roll on them and
jump on them and like
yeah i know but yeah point taken the
point is we gotta like see what we got
for boxes we maybe should see what they
use at like tempest or like rerunning
gyms or like some of that kind of crap
too like
it'd be super super useful
yeah but like that last shot of the day
like i'll never forget the look on your
face sam because it's like we're trying
to problem solve how to get
my uh because
the camera cannot go below the ground
it's real life you know you can't no
clip in real life but uh we're in the
shot where it's like i'm walking across
this bridge and we wanted the camera
looking up at me on this little mini
bridge here so we're talking about like
throwing down the crash pad or something
for me to stand up on and then sam's
like oh
no no he had he had an idea and i was
like
well what's the idea's like no it's too
sketch and i instant i was like oh
you just said the wrong thing sam
i am now all about whatever it is you're
about to say and he's like well you can
maybe stand on the apple boxes and i was
instantly like yes that's what we're
gonna do so we stood these apple boxes
you know it's like
one and a half two feet tall uh and i
was watching style new york style
exactly yeah
and so like the twin quadruple towers
there's like like four twin no four
individual towers that made up not
so it was there's like eddie it was hard
to do
yeah but like that that that was a thing
that we kind of came up with in the
moment it's like sure let's do it and
being able to walk across apple boxes
created this sort of
uh like tension for me on screen because
it's like i'm having to actually balance
these pillars these box pillars
basically if it was if it was just a big
crash but i would have had to fake
balancing but walk across this you're on
a tiny like slippery arch rock arch
ledge and so it's like well yeah that's
how you would act if you were up there
on this really high skinny way very
delicate because if i if i messed up i
will literally hurt myself
so that's how we like to do things at
corridor yeah so when we do lightning
spells we'll have small tasers around
yeah so when you cast it everyone's like
whoa like you throw a taser so it's not
as powerful as actual lightning but you
know just like we're saying here it's
easy you'll still get hurt but it won't
be as bad as falling off a cliff you
know right
yeah i guess what i mean by that is that
like that was that was the thing that
came about and over the course of like
maybe one minute
and then like executed on it in about
like five ten minutes the next thing you
know we're like shooting the shot that
was a bonus shot to begin with and had
already gone through like two or three
iterations on the actual idea for for
doing it and then we were done and we
got the shot and it's like
that was dope yeah it was actually just
as easy as every other shot we had set
up through that day too it was just the
only the difference was it was fun it
was a fun idea you know i think my
favorite moment about that though was uh
the pop-out green screen we threw down
because carmichael was filming and he
was way off to the side and so we've got
the big green screen that goes down and
then out onto the ground aways but that
green screen on the ground does end and
then it's just the regular concrete
floor and so carmichael was out and he
wanted to be able to look down into the
the chasm underneath this bridge but
when he pointed the camera down the live
feed was only shown on the ground and so
i think christian pulled out the pop out
green screen threw it down on the ground
suddenly
there was it was a portal oh fun and it
was like it was literally like the
freaking black hole portal from looney
tunes
that you just throw down on the ground
and now it's an act you could fall
through it
it was like the embodiment of that it
was like whoa i think we all just kind
of like took a moment to kind of be like
yo i know now we have to have that on
set all the time whenever we pan the
camera off the green screen and look at
something we have a little portal there
we can see what we're trying to look at
i love the idea of you guys being able
to build an actual set and just having
because it's so weird seeing where the
green screen ends especially when like
the ground plane is lined up with the
digital environment because it just like
there's no parallax shift or anything
it's just digital world practical all
moving
together and so the idea of like using
that to like
have this intricate complicated like
where's the cg start in like the real
life and like you can't you can't tell
like at all it's just completely and you
get to shoot in both as if it's like
practical yeah so the the dream setup
it's dope it's pretty cool i mean a big
thing for me this year has been the the
mantra of
fewer like less vfx more footage it's
like the more i can get done in camera
the better and so far my focus on that
front has been like ar-based stuff like
last fall i was able to basically do a
whole photo scan of me
bring that into miximo with the textures
and add a random animation to that and
then send that from mixmo to adobe arrow
which is their ar thing and then i would
open up my phone and then have that
animation just on my phone and just like
that i had a life-size one-to-one scale
version of me doing the freaking michael
jackson miximo dance
uh just tracked in real time in in
in the footage you know and it's like
okay the quality still isn't quite there
yet
but it's a matter of time is it this
year's iphone next year's iphone that
will have the better ar tracking in the
rendering to kind of like get it to the
point where it's like good enough that
you're like yeah that's a sweet shot and
all i had to do was just download a
model get it on my phone and we shoot
the take and now it's just footage i
don't have to like take this and make it
a vfx shot later even if it's a simple
vfx shot like the more of that the
better and unreal engine is like the
super high level version of that yeah or
the virtual production i should say it
is
i couldn't believe somebody sent me a
link to a model on my phone it was like
phones can't open models and it opens up
the camera and i'm like yeah you idiot
and then it's like no we put the model
in real life here
it's like we put it we place it behind
the couch it's just there in this yeah
the real world occlusion wait what we
can do
like we can do that and not just like
it's like i don't see any models like oh
it's like hiding behind my sofa i have
it's so funny that's so funny i love
that when you load that up you don't
know where it's going to appear so you'd
have to kind of like look around like
where is it
well like the uh the 3d scanning app
polycam is is great for that because you
can save out the scan that you literally
just got as a usdz file and you could
text message that so i will send those
uh models to friends of mine who
who know nothing about visual effects or
cg models or anything photo scans and i
just say tap that and then point it at
the ground
and they're like okay and then they do
it and it's like whoa
so like i just got a new one wheel tire
the enduro tire and i took a 3d scan of
it and i sent it to jeff the guy who
designed the tire really i was like just
open this and point your camera at the
ground he was like okay and he was like
whoa that was pretty sick
what i love is that it is a
two-scale too yes which is incredibly
yeah like i was saying um it might be
useful for you guys too um i did scan my
baby son that's like like how much me
too i have a 3d picture
capture of my daughter sleeping because
that's the only way they're still yeah
yeah but you got now now i've got like a
yeah i've got this like huge
baby right here it's huge this is the
daughter space you want to see this huge
baby in here
such a big baby oh my god massive
youngest child
a baby
too
it's like you have like the parents who
take a single picture of their kid every
day for their whole life it's like no
now we're at the point where the parent
is taking a 3d scan of their kid every
day just to kind of like
pose and then we'll run them through uh
russian 3d uh scanner
and create blend shapes between all of
them
and that way we can have the most
ultimate morph
3d models across time wait what is this
russian thing it's called the russian 3d
scanner it's literally called russian
three is this wait is this an app
it's desktop programming it's made for
taking like uh 50 photo scans of
someone's head in different expressions
and then re-meshing them and turning
them into blend shapes with texture
blending so when you do this you like
wrinkles whoa you got all your maps of
the wrinkles and stuff as the expression
changes
really complicated crap don't have time
to mess with it yo why did they pick a
name why didn't why sorry why didn't
they pick a name
it's literally just called
russian
3d scanner that's their url
anyways
man i'm still like i have been begging
the developers at cinema 4d or at maxon
to incorporate this one simple feature
when it comes to uv maps and blender has
it as a button
and that's and that's like basically
retargeting a texture from one model to
another model let's say you get a 3d
scan of
of a shoe right and you're like cool but
it's like a really high resolution mesh
and it's not good topology and whatnot
there's great automatic uh
retopologizing features out now that you
like really nice geometry on it and and
there's really good auto unwrapping
features for the uvw maps and it's like
great
but
i just want to take my nice the original
texture and put it on the new one and in
blender it's literally just a
retargeting bake out type deal in cinema
4d i have to literally like duplicate
the model do a normal move on the
polygons to expand them out where it's
kind of like ballooning it outwards a
little bit i have to put an ambient
light into the scene and on that second
model after reversing the normals i have
to put a chrome
material
on it a perfectly chrome material with
an ambient light and then bake out the
reflection map oh interesting of that to
use that as the new
diffuse texture on that same model which
i also had to duplicate again because i
don't want to have to like undo the
normal move i did so it's like and it's
like this super annoying process and
it's like with the rise of photo
scanning and and like one
like make this easy this should be easy
it should be a button blender does it
tell you one step like further because i
only got into this a lot in the past
year i may have even messaged you about
this like we'll do a scan um in the
studio then i take the hdri i've
actually been we've only texted over
this i've been wanting to talk to you
more about taking hdi in that exact
location i make another version of the
model uh that's just like grayscale
with the uh lit with the hdri so it's
actually
digitally calculating the light like i'm
making a texture map of just the light
hitting it uh that was there at the
actual location so you're actually
making a scanning spot let's say in a
studio you're like all right i'm going
to put this plant right here this spot
in space where all the lights are yeah
and you and you'll do the scan of that
and then once you're done with the scan
you'll create an hdri yourself in that
same exact spot 360 high dynamic range
yeah image that captures the entire
environment lighting from that location
uh individually i set them both back up
so i can calculate the light hitting the
model then i can
literally it's as easy as just dividing
those values from the original
texture map
and that lights that just straight d
lights like the the model
thing yeah yeah and it works bizarrely
bizarrely well it's one of those things
you're like i didn't think that now that
you're talking about it it makes sense
yeah yeah
because yeah it's like any time you
photo scan something you are literally
baking in the lighting that is there but
what you're doing is you're now taking
the hdri and kind of doing like an
inversion of that to kind of like
subtract out the darkness
or subtract out the lightness it's the
it's like
yeah i had it took a while for me like
wrap my head around it like how can you
just divide out light and then it's like
all of those different blend modes are
just litter like ad is lit just adding
the stupid pixel values i love your deep
dive into how screen works like it's
like okay take the inverse of these two
images multiply those pixel values
together and then re-invert it again and
that is literally how screen works
and then i was able to do that with like
a node setup of like all right invert
divide invert like oh yeah that's
that's great and that means because you
can't divide to like zero you divide
like you know point five by like point
one you're getting like
a tenth of point like it's just getting
closer to zero and then when you invert
that that means it's going to be like
almost to the white point but it's
always going to round off nice and clean
because that was the difference between
screen and that is that ad would always
like go blazing past that about one
it'll cure your addiction
it just takes the higher of the two
right no no no screen usually has a
little bit more of like a dampened
falloff than add
because it's it's it's doing this sort
of like weird sort of like
like asymptote type deal to the to the
highlights whereas ad is just like
literally adding the values which in a
linear workflow is the correct way to do
things like when we were it's
compositing in after effects like the
2.2 gamma it's the reason screen
was the one we liked more than add
because ad just was like
crazy and it's like switching to linear
so we were all at tfn
at the same time i think right cfn
uh the force.net oh yeah yeah for fan
films back in like 2004. that was before
my time everybody i know now is somehow
correlated to like that space and i just
think that's so it was such like a time
to be in a place that wanted to do wacky
do you remember that one short that was
like it was like a sith double-bladed
guy if i had another guy and i think
they did all the compositing was it
combustion
duel
was it the one with the cool ship on the
side of the cliff because that one was
yeah that was so good
duel
duel
my short film duel or two guys fight
all the best ones are just like one word
that like it was kind of a cool word but
that was because you couldn't
uh just put your video on the internet
like
web space was uh i don't know if it was
more expensive or if i was just 14 but
like you had to appease some video
streaming god like adam film there was
always like a process and so people are
trying to make films good enough that
like the force.net would host their fan
film and all of these things are like
you know i'd uh my friend teague posted
a tutorial for people like look having
five megabytes per minute of video is
that is unacceptable that's way too big
you're gonna use sorenson squeeze three
or whatever and like get it down to two
megabytes per minute please no one will
ever need more
more pixels than that the first video i
ever actually megabytes put together a
minute
that's like just a garbled like
calculator
dude gifs are higher quality than that
but yeah no the first video i ever made
which i actually put effort into i re i
edited it together i did a voiceover
narration duality
duality
it wasn't do it was duality reality and
he released like all of the behind the
scenes and stuff too and it was just
like there's certain people who are just
like eight years ahead of their time did
the graphics and duality the graphics
they're so good man
look at that i frame by framed all of
this
we're looking at some 3ds max [ __ ]
dude's like well he's talking to this
dude and like oh claire
i mean we have to like can we link to
that stuff the thing is it's it's dated
rendering technology but it's still like
artfully done yeah which goes i mean we
were literally talking about that
earlier today with the deep fakes
and the reason why jurassic park holds
up it's like the rendering quality is
second to the artistry oh man
if you can really like tailor what
you're making to be artfully done it
will hold up regardless of time you're
two people with two is it one guy
with a double double bladed sword fight
wait this is it one guy fighting himself
i think it is look at the context i
think that's why it's called duality
oh no
we got a little marco von moos over here
i know everyone was always i bet it
looks pretty cool ryan weber he's
floating around
yes dude i reached out to him to come on
to the show oh yeah uh and his response
was
i thought this day might come
but he lives out in arizona and so we'll
make it happen at some point
yeah no he's cool dude ryan versus
dorkman lightsaber fights was like very
huge very inspirational for me back in
the day
but yeah oh yeah i was saying a moment
ago like the first thing i ever made was
a
tutorial on how to get the scarab gun in
halo 2.
and i tried uploading it to the internet
before youtube was a thing it was like
it was i think it was christmas break
2004 and i was trying to like upload
this and the only website i could do it
on was like gametrailers.com or
something like that it was like super
early days of hosting and
i don't know it's it's it's one of the
most cringy videos ever i'm really glad
it doesn't exist you filming your tv
with the camera no no it was actually a
proper like game capture setup
uh which our family computer just
happened to have a video card with
component in
and so uh
or oxan it was like the red yellow and
white composite
composite i thought had a three
additional
uh component
this component or something because
whatever the xbox cable is the s video
that's the last video um yeah no it was
like
that was my only foreign
stuff
and and i was i
all of that that you guys were talking
about i was like that wasn't even
in my dreams
possible
did you did you guys do you guys
remember uh revelations source
relationships yeah the book
it was just this fantastic
six months it was like
dude i got all these old star wars books
and like i've got like
also i have these the the complete guide
to books where like the complete guide
to starships the complete guided
characters and like gideon was like hey
let's read this one this morning i'm
like all right so we start flipping
through and i'm like
just getting sad because it keeps going
to characters that are like retconned
it's like jason's and jaina solo han
solo and leia organized twins i'm like
this is a brighter time
this was a much better time when the
canon like kind of made sense and was
like cool
and i was just really sad oh interesting
i was just like oh all the stuff in this
book is not means nothing anymore like
nothing this is all that they deleted
this whole that's wait those books were
burned five years ago
i know i know
maybe i shouldn't be telling people i
have one i wouldn't i might get killed
yeah that was that was tragic
yeah anyways yeah so ladies and
gentlemen
i unfortunately need to wrap up my
podcast yeah just i'm going to go home
i'm also eager to get out of here for a
very specific reason bran got his gt
today yeah he's going to be watching all
my purchased full price on my own for
the record yes
which yeah i won't say anything more
about it
that's not true he's going to be saying
more things about it in the future
subscribe to not miss them yeah follow
around instagram to hear what he thinks
about it actually i look forward to
hearing your gt review
me too and uh compared to my gt review
and we'll take the two numbers and add
them together and divide them by
i was this close to going home for lunch
instead of going out with you guys just
that i could bring the gt into work to
get it charging
but instead you got memories so
thanks for the memories
yeah
cool thanks for joining us
complain about adobe stuff at all
this adobe like heat that's been
happening has actually
uh been quite positive not gonna lie
like from the people i'm not gonna say
who but certain people have been
reaching out that i'm very surprised to
hear from
uh and adobe people are non-adobe people
like the inventor of fusion oh yeah
at lunch that literally he switched over
to
fusion like recently like a month or two
ago and i'm trying to make that switch
right now too it's easy
great we'll talk about that more
on the next podcast
because it's a three two one